ride through the city like BR I'm on a
mission to get it ride through the city
like BR if you ain't pleas and now
Brandon six
Bo
sh Good morning
Vietnam what's going on everybody it is
Monday Monday morning January 22nd it is
9:01 we start a minute late that's on me
that's on me we have a special guest in
the building we have a very special
guest he doesn't have school today for
whatever reason some weird holiday come
here
t look who's here look who's
here tiger in the
House El okay get back back over there
love
you uh I'm not sure why you don't have
school bud any
idea came to work with Dad I said he'd
be here about 5 hours have backtack
shows get some meetings go back to that
car shop lightning still not done you've
been around some cool cars dude when I
was your age the coolest car I saw is
Corvette nope not a Corvette Grandpa
Shob your grandpa Shob my dad had a uh
Eddie Bower Bronco that we thought was
the bees
knees yeah there you go what is it is
the you you're coming up different dude
you've seen some cool stuff you've seen
some cool stuff uh what's going on kids
I'm fresh off the plane from Austin
Texas Boston Austin Austin
Texas uh where we did the fight
companion with the the one the only the
legendary Joey
Diaz Eddie Bravo and of course Joseph
Rogan it's it's on his platform if you
haven't seen it it's available right now
on Spotify so it's live on uh JRE
YouTube and then it gets uploaded to
Spotify so it's available right now on
Spotify right now it's the fight
compaign for UFC
297 and thank God for JuJu's uh smelling
salts those are juju uh smelling salts
uh bring that man up chin so Juju and
his girlfriend or wife don't to make a
mistake there but ju guu and his wife
are two brilliant people um wicked
wicked smart his handle uh uh I mean if
you just go to Instagram you type in
Juju it'll pop up he has like a Jillian
followers very
famous this guy nope that's a receiver
uh put ju guu uh and then put a m after
I think see if it pops
up I'll find him D yeah but uh if you
you can find that gentlemen on
uh Juju mufu yeah that's yep juji muu
muu Fu at the end there but they're his
smelling salt and him his wife came up
with this recipe that will knock your
socks off I wish I had some right now it
will wake you up and we definitely
needed it we definitely needed that for
UFC
297 uh yeah shout out to the smelling
salts from ju guu and him and His
Brilliant girl uh that put that formula
together because UFC 297 to be honest as
expected um you know when that card was
announced when you looked at it
especially to kick off the the 2024
pay-per-view series that the UFC is
doing UFC's comeing with some heat so
let's not give them too
much too much grief for this first
pay-per-view because they're the for the
rest of the year they are on fire but
this one um you know I think it was the
holiday season where they you know
obviously they put these cards together
months in advance um to give the
fighters and the whole circus enough
time to put this stuff together and have
enough adequate time to uh perform but
this one I think is during the holidays
they're just like man let's just get
this thing going you know we have a main
event the rest who cares so it was never
like this card was going to blow
anybody's socks off in the first place
then mix in a a lot of bad
fights um just stylistically a ton of
decisions um and then a controversial
Main Event uh the co-main event you know
I love Raquel Pennington she is a
Colorado product her story is fantastic
uh she used to be roommates with Johnny
Depp there's so much to get in there
with just a real Pioneer she's had so
much um ups and downs in a career for
her to be world champion could be
prouder of her and she deserves it and
uh Pen's probably the next uh opponent
for her to defend that title at
bantamweight that being said probably
the worst title fight of all
time not her fault more it's more on uh
Bueno Silva you know she ended the fight
on her back and uh just's kind of
sitting there she never really got
started had some good back control had
some chances for submission early on and
then after that it was just a very
lackluster performance especially for a
main event um yeah probably the worst
title fight in history it's up there
it's definitely up there top top threes
being generous for a title fight yeah
for title fight yeah not worst fight so
I'm saying for a title fight
tbla
um and then the main event um DDP Sean
Strickland so what are the positives
here I always try to see everything
positive positives are DDP proved all
the naysayers um Wrong by including I
wasn't a naysayer I just had questions
about his cardio his coach saying he you
know he can only breathe 5% out of his
nose whatever he said I thought that
seemed a little fishy turns out they
weren't line they weren't fibbing this
dude went five rounds Championship
rounds with a you know pretty insane
Pace pretty high uh output rate as well
against a a guy who's the cardio King in
Shan Strickland so cardio is not an
issue for DDP in any facet um do I have
a problem with DDP winning the fight no
no nobody was robbed
um looking at the fight again on my
scorecards head Sean Strickland 313
probably give him one two and
five one two and five um the comy strike
numbers obviously you don't want to like
lean into that um but you know 183 total
strikes to
140 173 to 137 um signicant 157 head
shot to 81 body DDP wins there legs DDP
WIS there controlled with the takedowns
did nothing with the
takedowns um you know I see the com
there driz also had six takedowns yeah
but what's takedown if you don't do
anything with it I think I think we put
too much emphasis on takedowns um
especially if the guy doesn't do
anything with it the guy stands back up
right away defends it that should count
as well but uh no one was robbed there's
robberies you know Johnny Hendrick GSP
there's there's definitely robberies um
you know Patty piml his fight against
Gordon that that' probably be a robbery
this here um close fight I can see how
you give it to DDP um that being said I
would give the champ the nod here uh
Strickland complained of a headbutt when
you see it things happen that's not a
things happen it's not like DDP had a
game plan ah headbutt him open up his
eye that happens um am I off on this I
thought there one of Strickland's worst
performances it was still a close fight
I thought Strickland he just never got
going he never it and I kept saying
Ran's like well it's a tough fight I'm
like no I I know all Strickland's fights
are tough I get I get that he just never
seemed to have that Strickland magic he
it he never got off the starting Gates
he it never the momentum never came the
the Relentless like the way he breaks
dudes mentally it just never got going
he was winning and he he was he was
doing well but I just never saw him kick
into that fifth gear and really try and
take over then he saw he did have some
reserves in the tank there in the fifth
because he open up in the fifth which he
definitely won you there's no doubt even
if you hate Strickland let's say you're
far left and hate Strickland can't stand
anything he does anything he says
there's no doubt even if you don't have
a trained eye for fighting that you'd
give Strickland one and five you tell me
you can't find a round for him two three
and four
so first round he did good fifth round
he kind of opened up let loose a little
more had more success that fifth round
energy I wish he would have done two
three and four not saying he can keep
that pace for two three and four but I'm
saying in spurts he just and he even
Nick sick was like let's go man like
let's go Bud and I just I felt like he
was holding back for whatever reason now
this could be credit to DDP because he's
such an awkward fighter Strickland is
saying I I'm trying it's it's just it's
I haven't seen anything like this I'm
freaking trying the fifth he's like all
right now I got it maybe so if the in
the rematch we hear a different story
see a different story but as a Big Sean
Strickland fan this why this one's tough
to call I told you I would not bet on
this fight I picked Strickland the
reason I picked him is I did have some
questions about ddps cardio and I
thought if went past the second that
Strickland was going to be able to just
swarm him with his cardio and take over
with the volume but DDP was like no fam
got this nose right and you know
so I just I don't know what it is I like
to hear what Sean Strickland says the
headbut thing doesn't really work for me
but I I would I'd like to know where
he's at mentally inside that Octon even
his demeanor it didn't like in Izzy
fight when he's like come on remember
when he's like kicking he's like come on
dude where are where's that where was
that bro where was that energy I just I
didn't see it just never clicked it just
all this trash talk and all this you
know all the stuff he says and all I
just never saw it
translate on Saturday night it just that
it it the switch didn't turn on I didn't
see that Relentless kill or be killed
attitude that we love Strickland four
again this could all if you ask him he
be like yeah dude you fight DDP it was
awkward as hell he's throwing these
bombs he's whiffing you know he missed a
ton I I'd like to see have we seen a
fighter Miss more shots on title fight
and DDP that was fun to watch though he
looks he looked like he was going to
fall down every time he punched wild but
he doesn't it works for him
technically again it works for
DDP from a technical standpoint you're
like what what what is
this so like if you go back and watch
like Izzy Whitaker the first fight
second fight you watch you watch a Izzy
fight against in you know uh Alex Pier
the first fight second fight and then
you compare that to DDP Strickland it's
just a different product I'm not saying
it's worse I'm just saying as far
as like tip of the spare world class
striking it's just different not saying
DDP or strick is not that but it's just
different it's just different the UFC is
in a win-win situation Strickland now is
a guy where it doesn't matter if he has
the belt or not if he's world champion
or not he's still a massive star people
didn't like Strickland because he's a
world champion people like Strickland
because he's outspoken and he goes
against the grain and he says things
that a lot of people are thinking and
would never say and he doesn't get in
trouble for it so he has that momentum
on his side those people are going to
ride with Strickland if he went over for
four in his next four fights he does not
need a belt to get the views that he's
getting so UFC's good there DDP vers
Izzy is the fight that they could make
that would get the most traction does it
happen at 300
I don't think so um from what I hear I
he's not going to be ready by 300 he
obviously want that long break so I
don't know if they get that hamza's down
he's tweeting out now I thought because
of Ramadan hamzat was out but he's the
one tweeting like let feed me feed me S
more he he wants
it um based off what we saw on Saturday
night does anybody think that DDP would
beat Hamot Izzy or Bo
nickel anyone in here T tiger you got
Hamad or
DDP DDP okay all right so you got one
tiger I mean I think it's possible yeah
oh of course it's possible I'm not
saying it's like a Landslide by hamz I
also got questions on hamzat after that
kamaro fight and and the issue is you're
giving you're giv hamzad a title fight
in middleweight and he's had he really
has what one legit victory in
middleweight division Kamar hman doesn't
count he's a blown up welterweight Ser
title shot it's just a hype with him but
I thought hamzo was even an option on
because Rogan brought it up on the
compar went you got Ramadan he ah damn
yeah he's out and I was yeah he's out
Ramadan I think the the funnest fight to
make for me would be hamzat DDP for 300
that that's a that's a good Main
Event CU they're they're sitting on Two
And I think Dan say is going to announce
the main event this week they're sitting
on the big announcer for 300 have I
heard what it is yeah I
have have you I can't come on just tell
us it's not what I do come on I can't
come on people told me and said you
can't say anything and that sucks for me
you think I'd love to break news what if
I just say things and then you nod or
wink wink nah yeah yeah CU those people
stop sharing info with me um but I could
see Hamot DDP happening especially since
since ramadan's not a thing hamza's like
I'll figure that out I'll fast during
the morning train in the morning eat at
night and
recover but I would say whoever DD DDP
faces in his next fight he's an
underdog doesn't mean you can't win him
I'm not saying that doesn't mean I don't
like DDP I think he's fantastic freak um
but if you line up Hamot Izzy or Bo nckl
which I mean the question he's not
getting a title shot but if let's say
they were to get a wild feather up their
ass and do it I think DDP is an underdog
in his next fight no matter who it is
including Sean
Strickland he'd be an
underdog like I said win-win for the UFC
Sean Strickland still a massive star
still getting Conor McGregor numbers as
far as content goes nobody else is doing
that Sean Strickland whether you like or
not as far as uh kind of Statistics go
online uh if you have the guy on the
show you talk about him we haven't seen
these numbers since Connor you know anex
said that and uh you know we see it here
everyone sees it um his Social Media
stuff like that there he's he's probably
the which just crazy he's probably the
UFC's biggest star right
now Conor's Still Still The King but
even that I'm sure we get to it in the
in the news
but Connor's breaking people's heart
because they asked Dana about is Connor
fighting in June he's like no no no
you'll hear it from us if he's fighting
like oh okay he's not fighting
middleweight no we' never do that makes
no sense y'all oh that's cool so Dana
says Conor is not fighting June when
Conor's ready to fight you know will
announce it that's why it was always we
we had no confirmation from the UFC you
think the UFC is just going to let
Connor announce his fight in that weird
video at some fancy restaurant and then
not follow up with it and it was a funny
we've heard nothing yeah CU we had
middleweight and you're like
okay I think this goes more
to which breaks my heart oh Conor's
probably not
fighting Casey's the biggest Conor fan
in the world you you love him you love
him but it's getting exhausting you're
like wait wait there was no battle
agreement at middleweight oh against
Chandler how about poor Chandler how
about Chandler just this side piece was
waiting for his opportunity it's never
happening girl move on it's never
happening girl it's a it's a bummer for
him
bummer uh so let's go through the people
that had uh strictly win the fight Dana
White and this sucks for DDP it breaks
my heart you see at the press conference
his eyes all you know he biggest night
his life biggest fight you know that
he's ever won and he's like hold on hold
on he see he you know he's he's been
fighting so you he's probably looking C
he goes hold on hold on are there people
out there don't think I won that fight
and the the journalist is like yeah he's
like like who he goes Dana White he's
all
[__] sucks Dana White Joe Rogan oh
when those two if you hear that you're
like oh no if you're hear me like oh no
then you got to deal with this onslaught
of [__] the poor guy he's like what
do you want want me to I'm not a judge
I'm not a judge still got the belt
around your waist though so I mean
doesn't matter yeah and Strickland he
has the best perspective on he says this
I wonder how he really feels he's like
the Belt doesn't mean anything he's like
what's it mean his belt means doesn't
mean [__] I don't get too attach to it
so I think he's good I think he's good
there's a lot left form him out there to
do
um that fight was weird the fight was
weird from a technical standpoint it was
weird it looked weird
looked very strange compared to like an
Alex pier and and Izzy fight you know
you have two like world class
Strikers stuff a lot of whiffing a lot
of missed opportunities you know Sean's
jab I mean that was super jab was world
class world class especially in the
beginning his defense world like there's
a reason why DDP was missing so much
Strickland's defense is world class
never SE anything like it again I don't
know what's going through Strickland's
head and I'd like to talk to Nick sick
about it there was just never this sense
of like the he he always breaks guys
will and it's he doesn't wait till the
fifth to do it it's usually this point
in the second or third round where you
see a just a switch flip and then it's
just this Onslaught until the guy breaks
and it just never came I was like Wai
and wait I went some Strickland's off
R's like yeah he's in a tough fight he's
been in tough fights before and then
there's something that's what makes Sea
different that it makes him a different
breed you can see his mentality switches
and he just kind of just slowly chipping
away chipping away chipping away and
then sudden it starts going faster
because it starts fight he's going like
this this is the Rhythm boof boof boof
second boof boof boof third boof boof
boof fourth fifth it
breaks this fight is just this the whole
time all one round first round second
round third round fourth round slow down
a little bit and fifth round
it's not his style that's what makes him
special is he just he's like a title
waveman until you break it just never
came it could that could be credit DDP
Sean might dude so damn awkward and we
thought his cardio was going to be way
worse it is actually better than we
thought didn't go how we planned we
never had the opportunity to try to push
him
so bummer yeah he looked super serious
the entire time during the walk out
everything like he didn't look like
himself didn't look like he was having
fun and he looks like a guy who he's
like hold on I can fight somebody not
get arrested like that's that's his Vibe
it's that American History X Vibe like I
can do this you're not going to arrest
me it was almost like like being a
champion defending the title finally
like all that pressure all he's famous
now he's he's like I'm a superstar in
Walmart right so it's like this is the
first fight we've seen him where he's a
legit
Superstar heavy lies the crown it's a
complete different ammo on your champion
I always tell you guys this complete
heavy lies the crown you got to do
different stuff the media is different
the ask are different the the the all
the stuff comes with being a champion
it's that's why I look at Izzy I'm like
good God give him a break man give him a
freaking break some guys flourishing it
other guys like what M khabib goes all
you got to do all you got to do is lose
and this all goes away that's all you
got to do if you don't like it just lose
once see what happens and even though
Strickland's a a big star now no matter
he doesn't need a belt to get these
views when you lose it just it's just
different when you're not Champion it's
just
different these these media Outlets they
they stop knocking on the door so his
next fight even it probably won't happen
the next fight he loses the next one
that third fight he's like what happened
to they don't want to interview me like
nah no request dog oh okay I'm not I'm
not the hot girl in school anymore no no
no no somebody else shout
ghost but some it was just something was
different about Shan strickling that
fight I don't know what it is I'd love
to hear what he says I just didn't get
those same Vibes that be killed kill or
be killed in there it just was different
could be off he like no I felt great
best night of my life okay no it was
just DDP was awkward as hell man just
couldn't get in a rhythm that's kudos to
DDP so we'll see but I do think DDP
whoever it is in the next fight
Underdog it'll be a slight Underdog no
matter who it is
and if you if you're Izzy if you're uh
Hamza you're licking your chops if
you're bow nickel dude you're foaming at
the Wier you're like that's the champ
sign me
up and the only reason B Nick is not
your champ is UFC's literally hold them
back like no no no yet we got to figure
we got to let the division figure
yourself out we can't just throw you in
there mop everybody up that's all that's
going on they're just like he's at the
gate like douche douche douche douche
and the UFC's like C hold D hold D and
just American white [__] battering
ram can wrestle their ass off hold you
know that's what they're doing and then
the bow nickel onslaughts going to come
and you're all screwed it's what it is
and his striking is great too
everything's good mentality everything
good luck good
luck he's Liam niss the rest of the UF
middleweight division just going good
luck and then he do to come
just but these are takedowns not
shooting yeah cart sucked
man cart was horrible thank God I was
with my buddies getting wasted we had so
much fun the great Joey Diaz I haven't
seen that guy in a hot
second he's doing it right man Rogan's
dying again to freaking Austin it's not
happening we had he had conversation at
dinner it's it's not happening dude oh
to live there to live there it's he's
like I'll come here you know three days
a month something just you know do the
club but yeah I ain't moving here man I
love Jersey good for him by the way I'll
be there in Austin with you on oh dope I
think Saturday 7:30 show yeah I'm
bringing a bunch of family oh you got oh
from Texas from Dallas right no no well
they're all over the placeas yeah hell
yeah that'd be fun yeah should be fun
your boy Neil Magny he was losing the
entire fight my God he's getting his ass
whooped Mike mot is a Savage he's like
the next Canadian Superstar looks like
Prince Charming was just beating the
breaks on 10 eight rounds and then Neil
just pulled it out got it done yeah P
Arnold Allen the UFC come on dud so yeah
most of it's like the UFC are do you not
like Arnold Allen I don't get it I don't
get it yeah I don't get it you you give
a Max terrible match up but if you can
get by by that you know you're off
running for a title and they're like oh
you had a really tough fight against Max
here's mosar you're like what what I do
it's just nightmare matchup for
him what else you got J all right quick
break DraftKings DraftKings Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner the
NFL playoffs is bringing an offer that
will help make the playoffs booming new
customers can bet five bucks on any game
and get 200 insum bonus bets
uh I had the bills bills were my pick in
the AFC to go all the way uh Josh Allen
did all he could with the team on his
back a lot of drop balls was tough so
you got the Chiefs you got Baltimore it
is tough to I'm not a Baltimore fan it
is tough to bet against
Baltimore um uh the NFC playoffs is much
more exciting to me uh you got Detroit
it's hard not to root for Detroit it's
just there's just that blue collared eth
work ethic that those boys have the head
coach I absolutely love he looks
identical to my boy Joe coffen Stein um
it's hard not to root for Detroit uh but
then also mcaffrey I'm the biggest
mcaffrey fan so definitely go for the
NFC uh whoever wins that game uh I would
probably side with the ners I think it's
their year so let's see what happens but
either way you go make some bank with
dra DraftKings download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use code shop
show new customers can bet just five
bucks to get 200 instantly in bonus bets
only on draftking sports with the cach
shop show the crown is yours hit it
gambling problem call 1 1800 Gambler or
visit ww. 1800 gambler. net in New York
call
8778 heny or text heny 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887895118
expire 168 hours after issuance see
dk.com for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming
resources this next one your boy has
been there nonstop this past week oh oh
oh Riley Auto Parts ow your boy's been
there nonf freaking stop uh had to pay
for all this stuff but that's something
we can talk about later I was at
O'Reilly Auto Parts I'm installing a 2.9
Whipple blower on my 2004 lightning and
uh you would think the Whipple uh
supercharger kit would come with
everything you need it doesn't we've had
to cut the firewall modify the firewall
uh the E EG valve line the brake line
Casey's had to shoot and dock all this
oh yeah how many how many runs have I
done to O'Reilly this past week seven it
was yeah we were averaging three a day
three a day in and out to O'Reilly shut
to O'Reilly they have stock OEM Parts
they have everything but uh for those of
you let me ask a question how long has
it been since you changed your spark
plugs replacing your spark plugs can
restore efficiency and performance to
your vehicle whatever you're driving
besides Tesla uh right now at O'Reilly
Auto Parts get a $12 O'Reilly gift card
after rebate when you purchase four or
more select AC Delco spark plugs
maintain your performance and fuel
mileage and new spark plugs from
O'Reilly Auto Parts these are my go-to
people that work there are super
knowledgeable I I needed a I need a
pulley belt a OEM pulley belt for the
for the Ford Lightning again my truck's
20 years old they had it in
stock I need a a special intake that was
4 Ines they had in stock they got it all
man so O'Reilly's my go-to that's why I
partnered up with them you can also
improve visibility with new wiper blades
La I bet you wish you had wiper blades
right now it's been raining nonstop it's
like a monsoon right now right now save
12 bucks on a pair of Rain X rugged XL
wiper blades plus get two times o Reward
Points an extra large profile and
premium features make rugged XL blades
the right choice for extreme weather
driving durability the professional
Parts people will even install your new
wiper blades for free from spark plugs
to freaking OEM Parts like I'm doing
non-stop these days run up to O'Reilly
save more right now do it right deals
and in store at O'Reilly Auto Parts
O'Reilly auto.com o
O'Reilly all right so we can't play this
video but um this is part of the
controversy on the UFC 297 uh the F when
Bruce Buffer called out the winner of
this fight Shawn Woodson and Charles
jordane so I'll just play the audio here
and it is kind of confusing so imagine
the guy on the left is Charles jordane
yes and then the guy on the right Sean
Woodson Woodson yes here we
[Applause]
go you said Woods in there in the end
but apparently in the auditorium is so
loud and apparently Toronto's like super
super loud so they thought I uh sea
Woodson and Charles jordane thought that
freaking Shawn Juan yeah oh sorry sorry
jordane ju they thought and he was like
giv
props damn that's awward and then later
on DC came in it's like no no Sean
Woodson won that's awkward as hell it's
so awkward yeah so it's not Bruce
Buffer's fault it's just like the it's
just too loud like playing Arrowhead did
they raise the wrong hand no they did it
the wait where was The Rev that's
another good point Why is the ref oh no
hold on let me play it again the ref is
in between no the ref that's why it's
confusing the ref raised the wrong hand
yeah there you go that's the issue and I
saw this live too I don't remember that
part but that's awkward that crowd was
wild F
tro F
tro Charles
Sean what no just saying saying loudly
Charles or
sea it's like it's it's a little and
then they said the nickname too the
sniper
Woodson but it's just too loud in there
I guess but the ref the ref confused the
ref should have helped everybody out
because the ref knows the but even the
ref probably couldn't hear
so but he knows which hand to
raise do they how does that work does a
ref know or do they listen listen to
buffer no they listen to buffer so
that's going to be tough they don't tell
them before oh they probably change that
going forward yeah that's a good point
they should change that going forward
buffer gets the thing goes looks at it
and then reads it yeah the ref's just
stay in there and he does this so that's
a good point though they should let the
freaking ref know ahead of time you
don't have to tell him the score card
you should like Woodson yeah
interesting they probably don't want the
like him the fighters to hear like they
don't you know they want natural
reactions um so Izzy did say like you
know Izzy said he's he's not sure when
he's going to come back but then
afterwards uh since drus dupes did call
him out after the fight uh Izzy said
this is kind of kind of something that
he's feeling like was a part of his you
know his entire Arc of his plan and this
Arc in my story was written long ago our
paths are destined to cross again stay
tuned for the next episode thanks for
watching we we write history yeah
there's footage of them sparring Back in
the Day 2016 they kind of bumped into
into each other so drus was sparring uh
Alexander volovski yeah and they just
kind of bumped each other that's a fight
to make there's a story there's a lot of
bad blood there you know you got to hope
it doesn't get too dark remember how
dark it got
so yeah there's some sauce there for
that fight but I think the UFC is fine
again the UFC wins no matter what
because they're fine whether it's Hamot
that's interesting um Strickland rematch
there's a lot of stuff you could do with
it yeah so that's you don't think that's
GNA happen on on 300 the right I don't
think so but who knows drus did say that
he's he would do it but he's not sure
he's going to be his body's going to be
in good shape you I like this about DDP
he's a guy who's like obviously he
turned down the izy fight that's how
stri became Champion remember the
shunned him and like hated him and then
eventually they just had to give him the
title shot I like that he's like no I
don't feel great no I'm not 100% I'm
good I'm going to wait like even when
they asked him they're like would you
fight is he at 300 you don't see him too
beat up he's like too beat up he's like
dud look at my face he's like I'm a
little beat up we'll see and he was like
300 sounds nice but you know he never
commits anything he's very smart very
smart with that stuff where most guys
are like yeah I'm down so then UFC's
like oh as soon as they hear that dude
get ready UFC is going to figure
something out for you whether it's Izzy
hom out something they're going to push
you into it if you're not 100% while
you're and now you're Champion dude he
don't have to do [__] that's what I was
going to ask you as you're Champion like
nah because they're not going to strip
him not not over 300 it's too close
obviously he's going to be suspended for
probably 60 90 days so there's that too
so UFC 300 is April
13th I'm I'm bad
February March April yeah some be
close uh so if you were in the same
position though right uh let's say you
won the championship for the first time
ever and then you had a chance to fight
at UFC 300 against a guy that you don't
like that I think you you think you
could beat I depends what he how he
feels I mean I I would give it two weeks
like don't talk to me or my team for
give me two weeks let me heal up see how
bad these injuries are you know who
knows Some Cuts because he's not g be to
train for a few weeks as well if there's
Cuts so I'd say give us two don't talk
for two weeks we'll accept we we'll
assess things from there and now you're
champ you don't have to do you don't
have to do anything also embrace it man
that belt's going to flip a lot and
again this is no hate on DDP he's going
to be an underdog no matter who they P
him up with next you can only be
Champion for so long so take your time
enjoy this moment man you've earned it
bud don't rush back in these next fights
are tough dude anybody who he fights
going to be [__] tough Embrace being
Champion go around go home enjoy it man
because it's gonna be gone like this
it's not knock on him not saying he
can't get it back I'm just saying these
next fights going be freaking tough take
your time embrace all this dude enjoy it
all your hard work is paid off man you
don't want to just forget about because
he's not going to enjoy it if they
announce 300 let's say this week okay
that's gone you you do the ride around
your local town in South Africa noone's
going to celebrate and you're back in
Camp you're not enjoying this you're not
doing the media KS you're not doing any
of that all that goes away if you accept
a fight 300 so I probably wouldn't do it
yeah I'm looking at Sean's record right
now he so he's been Champion for like
four months which is not that long that
kind of sucks but he did take it in like
quite a bit again Sean Champion for four
months DDP if he fights UFC 300 Champion
for two months you know if you were to
lose that again think how long stricklin
I'm sorry I he was Champion just nonstop
dude it's insane his body of work
insane all you mentioned this already
but uh so hamzat posted this picture on
X Twitter and just he put the you know
the digits three on the left corner zero
on the right corner and then zero on the
left corner so he's saying he's going to
be at or you know implying that he'll be
at 300 he wants to fight at 300 I know
he wants to fight for sure um what do
you think the odds are him fighting
pretty high pretty high yep pretty high
all right pretty high good to know
and so we talked about the sun fighter
and the kid but we didn't talk about it
here as as a Max hallway fan I love him
hate this fight oh really okay so the
odds makers I think on on yeah they're
on your side so of course so yeah Justin
gatei is going to fight Max Holloway for
the BMF belt and right now Gage is Aus
140 and then it jumped to minus 200 that
was opening odds and then uh Hollow was
plus 120 and then it jumped to one uh
plus 170 yeah I'd put Hollow like a plus
200 plus
250 hate this fight for him UFC
announced everyone's like oh my God BMF
I was like oh no this ain't it man this
ain't it he's not he at 55 doesn't hit
hard enough is he more skilled than all
of them yes can he outwork him yes it's
just for every four to five of his at
land all they got to do is land one we
saw with DP it's DUS and po it's not
good man it's just he's it's not I hate
it for him I absolutely hate it this
fight does nothing nothing for me wow
First Team all violence 100% you can
take punishment that probably career
changing
absolutely hate it hate it hate
it and um tiger doesn't like it
either this fight match up Max Hall
versus Justin gatei one's a natural 45
there's a
55 two most violent guys in each
division one's smaller than the other
doesn't hit as hard he's going to take a
lot of damage and Max got destroyed by
Dustin so and he did well in that fight
had a lot of success but again he got
hit he lands three or four and then all
it takes is DD uh Dustin pory lands one
it's a like it changes the the fight and
gatei with the leg kicks and I just
don't like it I don't like it as a Max
hallway massive fan I don't like it if
he wins oh my God what a story but I
just don't think it's worth
it yeah it's a tough one for sure he no
title shot after the you know like what
what bfm does what you don't get extra
pay-per-view number points nothing what
what are we going to
do yeah um and also we talked about this
on fighter kid but not here so Bobby
green versus Jim Miller so Jim Miller
will get his you know opportunity to
fight at UFC 300 which is great but
against uh Bobby green I like that
though it's not like Bobby's some young
chicken you know that's a great fight
Jim Miller can win that fight I have no
problem bet on Jim Miller in that fight
tough fight no no doubt can win
absolutely and what like can he win it's
like man how you knock him out I don't
know man you know it's just a bummer
yeah dude that's such a tough fight um
anyway uh so pfl and Bellator you know
they've been up in the air for the last
few months now we didn't know what was
going to happen but now well actually we
did we did kind of know that they were
going to fight each other the champions
from pfl and Bellator so they end
announce the fight coming up in Saudi
Arabia on February 24th and uh let me
show you some of the fights here so you
know online and obviously people you
know there's people that hate the UFC
and win championship so online people
like oh my God this is insane you know
what pfl and Bellator card does for me
does the same thing for me when I
watched two women went on
porn
nothing some of these matches were good
though dud but it does it it does not I
need some it do nothing yeah it do I was
like okay every was like oh this is
insane oh my God it's like uh okay two
more guys I've never heard
of all right well this guy is actually
kind like watching lesbian porn okay is
it a good product sure is it a good
product his headphones on oh okay yeah
my son yeah the whole time like looking
he has headphones on all right cool but
hen people think he's awesome what hen F
people think he's yeah that's the best
fight versus Ryan Bader hen and Bader is
a fun fight but again okay and impa KAS
kangai who won the pfl tournament for a
million dollars he's the one that got
knocked out that Viral knockout from
walking Buckley uh but he's fighting
Johnny eblin Johnny elin's a bad e might
be the best best middleweight in the
world uh I don't know much about Jesus's
P pen but he's F he's a Savage if you
want he's a Savage I'm just saying as
far as like are there going to be good
fights absolutely such fun fights great
fights as far as like star power like
people tuning in okay yeah yeah okay I
hear you I hear you um there's also yel
Romero fighting something either waygo
Santos yel Romero yeah that's a great
fight Collard AJ mcke fun fight Aon
Pico caressa
Shields there you go that's about it but
again this is like lesbian porn for
me
dude nothing wrong with it will I watch
it sure
sometimes uh okay I think I think this
was on DC and RC but DC mentioned that
the UFC wanted khabib back I don't know
if it was for 300 or whatever a few
years ago but they said he was saying
that khabib was offered 40 mil and he
still didn't take it to come back to the
UFC so he told DC uh that dude said 40
million to come back to fight in the UFC
they offered him 40 million I don't know
how many fights he was
meeting guess I'd assume at least four
uh I don't know what that meant uh but
he just said I turned away 40 million
brother I'm done I don't know what would
prompt him to come back if he's tur that
type of money away two years ago I
always said that people that say khabib
come it's never
happening it's never happening do you
have a better shot of Lesnar Ronda and
GSB fighting all in the same night than
you do kabib it's never
happening made a promise to his father
it's never happening he's set with money
he drives his little Toyota out there
you know in dagistan he's good man
alrighty um let's go here your boy Chris
Barnett he's been here before awesome
dude yeah he's going to be fighting
fight Kamar Us's brother yeah you know
who we're going for here of course March
23rd he loves it's all good
dude it's all
good um before we jump into
that another break quick
one listen when I started pod an online
store was the furthest thing from my
mind but I still freaking tried to sell
things I just started with fire kid
merch me and my brother sold it out of
my garage and we needed some help that's
where Shopify came in oh my God they
made things so much easier because now
all we do is use Shopify all right
Shopify is a global Commerce platform
that helps you sell at every stage of
your business from the launch your
online shop stage that's what we did to
the first real life store stage still
haven't done that all the way did we
just hit a million order stage Shopify
is there to help you grow with your
auction off autograph apparel skis car
parts whatever it is is they sell
everywhere from the all-in-one
e-commerce platform to their in-person
POS system where wherever and whatever
you're selling shopify's got you covered
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 36% better
compared to other leading Commerce
platforms all right Shopify Powers 10%
of all e-commerce in the US and Shopify
is the Global force behind Alberts rothy
and Brook lenons and millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
countries plus shopify's extensive help
resource are there to support your
success every step of the way because
business that grow grow with Shopify
Ching sign up for $1 per month trial
period at shopify.com shopall
lowercase all lowercase go to
shopify.com Shob now to grow your
business no matter what stage you're in
shopify.com Shob all lowercase CH Ching
last
one last one my favorite we're talking
about happy hippo it's 2024 and you've
always been on the fence if you're going
to use katum what you're going to use
the only one I use personally and I use
it quite a bit is happy hippo this stuff
helps me tackle all the crazy stuff
being a dad going to driving the sports
I'm basically an Uber driver now uh
working out podcast standup whatever it
is it's the best all right um it's not
like an energy drink it's more like you
get this warm balance good mood feeling
get your brain firing on all cylinders
which God knows we need uh right now my
favorite are the shots the the highly
concentrated shots they have the K dips
I recommend they have powders they have
gummies they have Taffy they got it all
so this is the One-Stop shop take out
the middleman take out the guest workout
all you got to do is go to happy
hippo.com use the code thick with three
C's 24 save 20% off the best Crum on
planet Earth the only company I trust to
put into this body all right this Temple
of a body go to freaking happy hippo.com
promode is thick
24 Al
righty um all right so Jon Jones's
brother Chandler Jones who's been in the
news recently because of erratic
Behavior you the cops and stuff but he
was on the Jackson podcast where Rampage
Jackson's on as well and he was
mentioning that he I think this is
during the break when the NFL let him go
he asked Dana White for a 10-day
contract or something like that to fight
in the UFC and of course nothing came
from it but no no the UFC can't do that
and there's more to this episode I
didn't watch all of it but yeah he
talked a lot about his brother and their
background and history and he also said
that he was him and his brother were big
fans of Rampage Jackson Growing Up So
when they fought like you know that was
one of Jon Jones's scariest opponents
weird
yeah yeah it just doesn't I told Dan
white sign me that 10day contract I'm
trying to get back in the NFL though for
real it's easy money that was giving me
18 million a year 17 million a year to
go f up on these little boys and the
football player certainly has strength
to compete in the UFC yeah doesn't mean
he can fight UFC can't do that I could
see him put him in Contender
series I mean I'd watch it that'd be
yeah that that would make it more
interesting for sure but with no
background we can just launch you in the
UFC I think didn't Jon Jones say his his
other brother um the D tackle the bigger
one helps him out oh but I thought he
said that Chandler would beat him up
like like he can mess up I I think I
recall that from way back in the day but
I could be
wrong um anyway uh reporter
Bruner hit up Dana White about the
Anti-Trust lawsuit and Dana White just
said uh or Aaron Bron
stadter this is what Dana White said
when asked no Dan White cly responded to
the question he was concerned about UFC
going to the trial in April in recent
interview I give literally zero thought
to it I don't think about it ever it has
nothing to do with me isn't he in the
last I could have of course he's yeah
he's one of the main guys yeah yeah
well he just didn't probably didn't want
to give him anything to run with you
know it's it that's can be interesting
for
sure yeah so it says here uh the payout
could be upwards of 811 million to 1.6
billion in Damages if the UFC loses
which even if they lost they'd be fine
they'd be fine but that's a that's a
pretty I mean 1.6 bill as I hit yeah
they'd be fine though all right so you
always talk about the Real Housewives of
UFC this was actually making the
headlines for a while now so Alex paa he
recently broke up with his girlfriend
and then he was on a full send
podcast and they asked him about like
you know what happened with this girl
and he mentioned that oh she was married
and she didn't tell him or something
along those lines so they've been doing
this back and forth and let me show you
just the main part of it right here
after he said that on the on the uh
podcast this is how she replied um hurt
man are really trying to invent whatever
obviously I was married in the past Alex
was too but I got separated before I
started a relationship with Alex you
guys are so stupid to think I could move
to the states having a husband LOL I
broke up with Alex by the way and if if
I would start to speak about the reasons
here it wouldn't end good guys and there
Alex
response uh I don't care about this [__]
but's see um yeah real housewives of I
don't know why people care about person
life headlines
um well let me just shorten it for you
so he was saying that I have a video of
her attacking me and she did didn't get
what she wanted and trying to go up with
my name yeah just sounds like better you
know
[__] I'm sure Alex have no problem no
and then also on the real real
housewives so this is remember that the
the the text messages came out because
of the antitrust lawsuit and then yeah
they're saying how uh difficult so this
is how uh DC responded with it so he
said some Dan White's text M were leaked
in regards Jon Jones we've all had bad
employees with Jones about being at the
at the fight doing the promotion being
easier to work with and then Jones never
let a bad employee beat you up and take
everything from you twice it'll leave
you bitter for a really long time yesh
yeah so they were cool for a while but
then I guess this happened yeah I
don't again John was a knucklehead back
in the day you know those tchs I'm sure
they said worse things than that it's
not the end of the world they still PID
John a ton of money still gave him
opportunity you know
yeah all right dude I think that's good
for currents but let me show you real
quick there's really no fights coming up
except for this one which should be
pretty cool it's one championship Super
League Super Le yeah versus taka by the
way super Le's like 28 years old he has
like over 130 something wins plus our
boy Kade ruto's uh grappling lightweight
submission grappling Sage North cut
returns Sage North cut against AI aiyama
Nikki holon that's like a super fight
where it's kickboxing boxing then they
do MMA I'm afraid for akiyama those
first two are going to be a nightmare to
get out of you got Gary tonin as well at
that and he's not doing grappling that
he's fighting at
featherweight yeah so that's that's a
pretty fun card for this weekend January
28th in Tokyo that'd be fun that's a
great one is that it that's pretty much
it all right kids Thursday I'm in
Nashville one night only and then Friday
Saturday I'm the stepmother ship the
Vulcan gas theater that is January 26
27th with a special guest uh January 26
27th at the Vulcan in Austin one night
only in Nashville Tennessee Zanies get
Jo tickets at thick boy.com is that it
all right kids love you like subscribe
do your thing be nice to each other see
you next time